au huitième jour de la contestation les
manifestants colombien s'attaque au
coeur du pouvoir législatif le capitole
la place à bonneval s'est transformée en
champ de bataille
la marche d'aujourd'hui se voulait
pacifique
nous sommes devant un gouvernement sourd
muet et qui refusent de nous voir et
encore moins de discuter avec nous ce
gouvernement est contre le peuple est
contre la nation affirme cet enseignant
la droite colombienne au pouvoir a tenté
d'instaurer une réforme fiscale qui ne
passe pas et qui ne serait que la partie
visible de l'iceberg
le peuple s'est rendu compte que
derrière il ya deux réformes comme la
réforme à la chanter ce qui va
précariser un peu plus les gens de notre
pays un peuple à bout de souffle qui a
laissé éclater sa colère
s'attaquant même à des postes de police
le bilan en vies humaines et lourd
l'état en ce moment est en train de
sortir les militaires dans la rue ils
sont en train de sortir la police les
tanks est en train d'utiliser de la
retirer lourd
le président colombien blâme les
manifestants plus de 500 ont été arrêtés
il banalise mois extrêmement le
vandalisme extrême et le terrorisme
urbain que nous observons sont financées
par les mafias du trafic de drogue
la crise sanitaire que traverse le pays
et le retard de la vaccination creuse
l'écart entre les riches et les pauvres
attisant encore plus la grogne du peuple
ici hasmik ryan radio canada montréal